The Council of the
Arts is and will
remain, in my opinion, one of
the most important legacies
of Dr. Jerome Wiesner.
Council for the Arts at MIT
was founded by Kay Stratton
and Jerry Wiesner.
Jerry was totally
devoted to the arts,
so that he picked up
the little art committee
and made it into the
Council for the Arts.
Jerry was a very strong,
anti-nuclear person.
He was President
Kennedy's science advisor,
and felt that
institutions like MIT
were turning out a lot
of students and graduates
of very high technical
expertise who
had a fairly large probability
of destroying the world.
And it was very important to
get involved in things that
have some sense of humanity.
They look good.
This is nice.
That's real nice.
Yeah.
That's a beauty.
They found that MIT really
had tremendous strength
in the arts, and that
the arts perhaps were not
getting the kind of resonance,
the kind of visibility
they should and ought to
have, because they thought
of the arts as very much
part of the mainstream of MIT
very much part of
the core mission.
When the council was
created 40 years ago,
it was almost unique.
There may have been one
or two others of its kind.
Where else but at MIT?
We like going first.
[CLASSICAL PIANO MUSIC]
[TECHNO MUSIC]
The view at that point, which
is very strange looking back,
is if we're going to
do art, let's buy some
and put it out in the campus.
In retrospect,
that was brilliant.
Public art collections
on university campuses
were ranked back in 2006,
and MIT was in the top 10,
and we love showing off
this public art collection.
The two most recent
pieces acquired
was Anish Kapoor's
sculpture, which
is over in the Stata
Center and Cai Guo-Qiang's
at the Sloan School.
[UPBEAT DRUMMING]
The grants program was the
most vital thing CAMIT does.
Over the course of
the years, we've
given over 1,000 grants away,
several million dollars.
A lot of the money we
give allows these people
to get money from other people
probably two to three to one.
These grants impacted
my work in ways
that I had to think
about community.
A mask that maybe--
These grants are meant to
provide for interaction
between students and faculty.
We think it's almost exposed
and it's just an [INAUDIBLE]----
This is where a lot of
my work has evolved.
The Council is very important
that it supports the arts
here in many different aspects
in carrying the word of art
to the world and allowing
us to develop and flourish
in the Institute.
So thank you.
CAMIT's support of the MIT
Museum and the List Visual Arts
Center is another
wonderful dimension.
We give money to the BSO so
that MIT students could get
tickets-- they're
either free or cheap--
money to the Gardner
Museum, and to the MFA.
We give money every year to the
Artist-in-Residence program.
All of my interactions
with the council
have been student-focused.
We've had residencies where
artists will come in and work
with the ensembles.
Joe Lovano is probably one of
the greatest tenor saxophone
soloists in jazz, and we were
able to get him to come to MIT.
And the students
rose to the occasion.
It was a wonderful
example of how,
when they're in the
presence of a great master,
they just lift
and lift and lift.
The McDermott Award was
founded by Margaret McDermott,
the widow of Eugene
McDermott, the founder
of Texas Instruments.
Mrs. McDermott decided,
after Eugene died,
that she would like to give
an award every year to artists
that are mid-career.
Let me confess.
I love Santa Domingo.
I love coming home to
the guys in blazers
trying to push little cups
of Brugal into my hands.
And it has attracted
wonderful people.
Junot Diaz, who
we later recruited
to our faculty, a prominent
New Yorker writer,
Pulitzer Prize winner.
Diller and Scofidio,
two architects
who were unknown at the time
they were brought to campus,
later became world
class architects,
and are among other things
the architects of the ICA.
In all cases, the
people who get the award
spend some time at MIT with
the students in some classes.
It's like learning
baseball from Babe Ruth.
But don't be nervous.
Da-da da-da da.
Da-da da-da da-da da-da-da na.
Da-da da-da dum.
[LAUGHS MISCHIEVOUSLY]
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
You know?
Four and--
[ORCHESTRA PLAYS]
The young conductor of the
Los Angeles Philharmonic,
Gustavo Dudamel, came
here to receive the award.
When an audience--
Most recently, Robert Lepage,
the Canadian theater maestro,
everything, he does at all.
With experience we've
learned that we should not
force connections.
We let them, and eventually
two or three things
seems to go together, and we
go, oh, there's a pattern there.
And so the award has really
evolved from a nice award,
to an important,
intermediate Artist Award,
to one of the highest
level awards in the world.
CAMIT has always
been an organization
that socially bonds,
that goes on trips,
has wonderful art
trips getting into very
exclusive private galleries.
We've been to Prague,
we've been to Berlin,
we've been to Chicago.
[MUSIC]
It's not at the
cutting edge of art,
it's at the cutting
edge of people.
I mean you're meeting
very smart people.
Among the most
important reasons one
should join CAMIT
is you get closer
to a truly great institution
of higher learning.
[GLASS CLINKING]
At MIT, we are very
much oriented toward art
at the intersection of
science and technology.
To find out what can we do
that will change the world.
The best works that are
developed in our classes
here come from students
who are brilliant people
from mathematics,
material science,
or mechanical engineering.
Art opens their view
and possibilities
beyond the
problem-solving agenda.
[ORCHESTRA PLAYING]
CAMIT has been generous to MIT.
It is the single most
important sponsor of the arts.
[ORCHESTRA PLAYING]
The Council for the Arts at
MIT gives an additional voice
to the arts.
It's this kind of
nourishment that the council
provides that really makes
a difference in what we're
able to do.
It's about a concern about
what the arts mean at MIT.
[ORCHESTRA PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]